so it's like she's saying like if you're
sleeping around now like then that like
um i think that's really reductionist um
so if you knew me uh i was suicidal i
tried to kill myself a couple of times
um and so if you knew me who i was um
even a year ago no no actually not a
year ago year ago was good but two years
ago i was very codependent i was very i
had very low self-worth i had and so to
be like your past actions determine who
you are no you've spoiled about
self-awareness
you can't say if a guy went to prison
three times for for
attempted battery he might do it again
oh no 100 i understand like you you can
say that you can't say that but to
reduce a woman to be like oh just
because so i was very codependent and so
the men i date now
would be like well based on your history
you want a relationship with me you're
going to fall in love with me and i'm
like you are very confused i don't want
that at all right now i will because i'm
very different
i've been i've been single by choice for
a year and a half like that's not a bad
thing it's okay to like fall in love
like a year and a half it's been a year
and a half and i've not yeah yeah but
but i'm i'm saying like
can answer your question
if you met a guy that you really liked
and you were considering him for a
relationship
and he told you that he had cheated in
every relationship previous to this
are you saying that would not at all
impact his desirability to you
for a boyfriend no i'm not saying that
i'm not again that's it it's not black
and white it's not one-size-fits-all i
will i will keep saying so i'm going i'm
blue in the face it's not
one-size-fits-all it's really not saying
not saying that it'd be like not saying
it's the deciding factor but like
would it not shift your opinion of him
potentially as a boyfriend or do you
think that would not impact your view of
him at all no no being being realistic
yeah you would be being a realist yeah
and the same way so you'd understand if
a guy viewed like
basically sleeping around a lot the same
way but then we've got yeah yeah but
then we've got
um if you have like 500 days of summer
is one of my favorite films and she says
when you know you know and i've dated a
lot of guys who are like i'm never going
to be relation i'm never going to i was
like well you will you will meet someone
at some point in your life it's probably
inevitable that you will meet someone
that you're like i'm going to settle
down i don't agree with when you know
you know i think that you make a choice
and like that's it like i don't think
most people well yeah
that it's the right choice but i'm
saying i don't think you'll ever know
and i think that's like a lot of like
now fear today and like dating today is
people thinking that they're just gonna
they're just gonna know but all you can
do is make a decision with the
information that you have but then yeah
but then you'll know that like
and even nowadays like people are dating
like what a decade five years three
years before they decide to get married
do you think those people just knew if
they're dating three
like
three years like i don't think they know
it's the one i don't believe in the one
but i think they know that they
especially and so it that research shows
that women will kind of um
look for that long term men will get to
a point where they're suddenly like
ah [ __ ] i kind of need to settle down
now ergo i'm gonna look right if she's
here and she fits in she'll do so men
actually technically end up settling and
they don't know why is that one why is
it settling it's no it's it's they just
made a choice they said okay yeah i'm
looking to like get married in this time
frame this girl fits everything i i i'm
looking for but she doesn't necessarily
fit everything they're looking for
that's why because people aren't perfect
so i don't i don't think it's
really settling if you say okay she
doesn't have everything like it's kind
of like do you know what she'll do yeah
she'll i think women could be better but
she'll do yeah but i think women like
probably could you know have a little
bit more he'll do yeah yeah i don't
think that's a bad thing because i'm not
perfect yeah i can't expect the guy to
be perfect
and so like
yeah like i just i don't like the word
settling it's not settling yeah i i like
you agree because especially with like
romance and like novels and like films
and stuff you believe that there's this
idea of the one and i know and it's like
you actually don't you actually just
need to be okay with what is and what's
happening and be like will you want more
probably a lot of people in
relationships and marriages you can ask
someone to be like what do you love
about your partner what do you not love
what do you wish was different like even
i would not date a snorer and that is
and that's uh if you don't have a
driver's license and you snore and
people like well that's not me people's
fault doesn't it i was like i literally
know that i would want to kill you if
both of those things weren't a thing
yeah but if i really loved a guy then
i'd be like well [ __ ] it i don't care i
don't know i say like girls have all
these standards until they met the guy
that makes them not care
but then it's like well do i do i know
or am i like yeah but here's i always
say i'd be the type i swear to god i'd
get married in six months because i feel
like there's risk there's risk
regardless
i'd rather just do it and hope for the
best and if it doesn't i'll get divorced
like but like i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna go into something
like okay being afraid of divorce
whatever it happens i hope it doesn't
happen to me like do you think you would
be more afraid of divorce if you're a
man
oh yeah i absolutely would yeah because
mine gets screwed over so oh actually no
no i got i got
i'm in this situation i should be afraid
i should be afraid
you should actually yeah you should but
nah i mean i think like again there's
risk with everything like so you think
if you're if you're a man you would look
at marriage as openly as you do now
um
probably not probably not i have a
question do you think your dad if he was
in our generation would get married
today yes you think he did yeah he he
wants my brother to get married oh yeah
no i mean my dad my parents are more
like traditional so oh that's something
like
like i don't know i think there's a lot
of legal issues and problems that like
i'll advocate for for matt like they're
not represented fairly in court like i
don't i don't think that you should be
able to take half a man's income just
because you had a kid together yeah i
think i'll be i think the laws are only
going to change
in
not the next generation next donation
after because a lot of men are saying
they're not going to get married because
of it and i think because women still
want to get married they're going to
start advocating for those laws to
change yeah no probably i think that's
right
just quickly
piggybacking off of that i think a lot
of like yeah you're saying men don't
want to get married women do and there's
a lot there is still a lot of dependency
upon like taking a man's name and like
getting a mortgage all that stuff but i
really want to know how do you feel
about like
dad's giving their daughter away
oh i think it's a really cute tradition
i wish i would i tell my dad i was i
tell him he could pick out my husband
all the time he doesn't want to though
he says i've got i'm busy
oh
so for me it'd be nice if he's like no
i'm not going to pick your husband you
pick someone that you think is well
that's kind of what he does he's like
because if it goes wrong you'll blame
me says like i'm not being in charge of
that i have to meet your dad at some
point if he's ever in london you have to
tell me oh no
and you know i know from that's it my
own bias and my like poor relationship
my dad i'm like i hate the idea of
belonging to a man and being given to a
man but i know that actually if i had a
good relationship with my dad i'd
probably be in your shoes i'd probably
yeah it's actually really sweet i mean
because you're i think like as women i
mean
we're attracted to shitty traits and we
can't really help it like i'm freud we
have a field day no like we like
[ __ ] we do i mean and i understand
like the science of why it's like the
dark triad traits like the same trait
yeah can you can you define the dot
track because i only discovered this
recently oh god i don't remember it off
the top of my head but it's like
like a guy that's aggressive right like
why do women stay with the men that like
beat them because the same men that like
are aggressive and like beat them can
also beat up someone else so it's the
same trait right a guy
like a guy that's controlling right he
also can control the environment yep
yeah so it's i don't remember all of
them but it's like it's like the same
traits that make a guy like completely
like an awful like partner also make him
a really good one yeah so i i have a
question for the ladies on the panel um
if you know that this is what you're
attracted to why do you think so many
women say they just want a nice guy
i don't think they realize that thing so
do you yeah i was gonna so my next
question was do you think a lot of women
are unaware of what they're actually
attracted to yes
yes i really think it comes from
inexperience because at the end of the
day being nice is not enough it's really
not enough it's the bare minimum it's
like breathing it's like i don't think
being nice is actually
admired to be honest like like condition
like unconditional kindness from a man i
think is seen as weakness totally
because well it's because like it's a
guy that doesn't like because a lot of
times this is this is my experience a
lot of times guys will say they're nice
but they're not they're not actually
nice
they're not nice they're afraid to stand
up for themselves and they're they like
we don't like guys that put us on a
pedestal like why do we think we like
like guys that make fun of us a little
bit yeah because you're treating us like
we're human so if we say something dumb
and you call it like
you know yeah or they think they're nice
because they're like well i'm not raping
someone i'm not beating you up ergo i'm
nice and i'm like
[Applause]
experience but yeah no i think everyone
guys say they're nice they're like i've
given her everything i take her here i
do this i do this i think it's a lot of
guys that go above and beyond for women
but women don't respect guys that give
them everything without making them earn
it but then we get in cell culture and
so it's like men who are like i'm xyz
it's like you're not though you're not
as good as you think you are you are the
best being nice is the better well i
think incels are kind of a result of
women not settling
and like like women saying i'd rather be
alone than have to settle instead of
like i don't know and then this goes
back to i actually think men are not i
actually think and this is i actually
think as much as i'm for female
empowerment and like i actually think
men end up settling more
and i think men actually end up
disappointing themselves more being like
if you asked a man write down your
perfect word on paper and let's compare
it to the woman that you ended up with
i think that yeah i think a lot more
women are actually like i'd rather be
alone than settle but then it's like you
actually could be alone forever if
you're not willing to settle if you're
not
but you can but you can't you can but
then you'll be homeless yeah yeah most
women you need 2.5 million to retire
um
i in regards to men settling i think
that i think men just don't have a lot
on their list
for women i think they just want
honestly i think
i think the majority of men in terms of
long term just want a woman who's warm
kind and peaceful
um and as if she's that with a low body
count
well yeah ideally i think ideally but i
think even if she i think that's i think
that is a preference but i think i think
the difference is like
men don't have a lot of
conditional points whereas i think a lot
of women have conditionals so a lot of
women will make their preference as part
of the condition
you know so she's like okay a guy has to
be six foot if he's not six foot i'm not
gonna entertain him whereas a guy might
be like okay i'd rather she's
four inches shorter than me but she's
the same height i can live with that
i think that's do you know what i mean
so i think a lot of them make that
preference i've never had a guy reject
me
but it's
it's so funny is that um
like you see a lot of men who are like
if you're like xyz like a lot of dating
profiles are like if you're like not xyz
like don't even bother like if you're
learning if you're not we've got
anything we've got to be skinny we've
got it but that's that's in our control
i like do not even feel bad bad for
women that get rejected because of their
weight like okay i've been overweight
like i'm like statistically
and it was my own damn fault and you can
lose it
to be fair like uh
i can say i can say this from like a
thin privileged point of view that i'm
like something privileged you've earned
it one there well i haven't earned it
though i haven't earned it at all you
did from a calorie perspective you ate
less than other people yeah but that's
because of adhd that's like i just don't
eat okay
yeah look like that's a privilege you
could call it eating less
but but then but then it's like there
are some men who love a chunky woman or
someone who are like you know what it
doesn't matter to me exceptions
exceptions that's the exception's not
the rule yeah exactly and and every man
and every guy you see that's rich and
and can has has his pick of women yeah
yeah who do they like i'm gonna be real
most women if you ask them would choose
to be thin like we're gonna be real
about that